the jennifer lopez and alex rodriguez
saga continues
there was such a misconception a source
tells e.t the pair
remain a couple adding like any
relationship they have ups and downs and
are working through things
all this comes after multiple sources
confirmed to et that jennifer and alex
split after four years together
effectively calling off their two-year
engagement
and jennifer certainly has something to
say about
all the headlines i worried about a blog
or a [ __ ] she posted this cryptic video
to her socials
referencing all the recent reports where
did the wedding plans stand where you
know what
can't share those deets right now the
two got engaged in march 2019 but were
forced to postpone their italian wedding
due to the coronavirus pandemic i
think we're very alike in many ways
and i think that's what makes it work
and i think that's why people
respond to the fact that we got together
we're like except i can't sing dance act
and i don't look like her besides that
we're twins oh yeah you look horrible
yeah
yeah yeah yeah right yeah people can't
stand the way it looks
it's we complement each other in a in a
beautiful way
and i couldn't have asked for a better
partner in this
one source previously told et quote
jennifer felt like moving forward to
marriage wasn't right
recently alex's character has been
called into question
and that didn't sit right with jennifer
the couple will always have respect for
each other
in early february alex's name popped up
in an unexpected place
on bravo's southern charm when tabloids
linked him to one of the show's stars
madison lecroy you were flying around
the country sleeping with
married men ex-mlb players you flew to
miami
to an xmlb player a source told et at
the time that alex had never met madison
and doesn't know her
while madison told page six they never
met up but did claim they've spoken on
the phone
where things go next for j.lo and a-rod
remains a question mark though
our source now says there is no third
party involved
she's currently working in the dominican
republic and he is working in miami